hi guys  how are you good well we  we loved you as a superhero i know we're  going to love you as an iconic villain  but who are you pulling your villain  inspiration from oh  i actually don't have like people  inspiration  i went through and it's very easy to do  with snow white because snow white has  so many for real psychological  researches because essentially it's a  relationship it's a dynamic relationship  between a mother and a daughter and what  happens when it goes really south and  really dark so i did so much reading  about that and it was easy for me to  understand so much of it because i have  kids i get it i can see where it can go  wrong  and i just  embraced myself into the psychology  system  of the evil queen and i  loved it  thank you